[Música]
[Aplausos]
de mi primer terreno hace unos años
estaba atravesando una situación
complicada laboral con mucho mucho
tiempo libre poco dinero
y logro mi primer terreno estaba
alquilando necesitaba obviamente tratar
de dejar de alquilar así que me fui al
lugar me parece y dije tengo trabajo
tengo que hacer una casa
algo que nunca había hecho y una idea
que obviamente me abrumaban me daba
miedo sí bien hice la escuela técnica y
tenía algún manejo de pequeñas
herramientas nunca había hecho una casa
de modo que bueno empecé a buscar alguna
técnica de construcción que se adaptará
a mi situación
así pasando por varias por varias
técnicas llegué a conocer la
construcción natural o bioconstrucción
en este caso dentro de todas las
opciones que hay la construcción con
adobe por ahí se ha pensado que en
nuestra zona no hay una tierra apta para
este tipo de construcción bueno fui
descubriendo que nuestra arcilla y
nuestra arena son dos elementos
principales en el adobe son de una
calidad maravillosa aquí en nuestra zona
convoque a una amiga arquitecta gabi
y ella también me termina de convencer
ban le pedí que hiciéramos el diseño de
la casa empezamos a armar este un diseño
que se adapta al sol este diseño
bioclimático y me terminó de convencer
porque ella también venía incursionando
en el tema tenía alguna experiencia así
que empezamos a hacer algunas pruebas
del material porque como no es estándar
hay que hacer algunas pruebas para
llegar a la proporción y si un momento
después de dos o tres meses de hacer
probetas y probarlas y romperlas y ver
si se rajaban dije yo quiero hacer una
pared
en el terreno así que este otra vez la
idea de la casa era abrumadora
le dije hagamos un baño chiquito para
tener un baño en la obra para la gente
que trabaje eventualmente y esto se
decidimos hacer un baño de 1 metro por
un metro el primer metro cuadrado
ahí empecé a ver cómo respondía el
material yo también tenía mis miedos y
mis preguntas para contestar necesitaba
ir probando distintas técnicas así que
cuando el baño ya iba tomando forma
y que hagamos un galponcito de 4x4 para
guardar las herramientas que tenía que
ir incorporando mezcladora carretilla
para las protegernos del calor del
verano que es muy intenso a la
intemperie aquí en el centro de la
patagonia y el frío del invierno
obviamente comenzamos a hacer ese galpón
citó con una técnica que se llama para
el francesa ok hincha
se suele hacer una estructura de madera
y se reviste con el barro por afuera y
por adentro aquí usamos los palets
porque son materiales de la zona se
pueden conseguir fácilmente entonces
esos palets daban la estructura a la
pared que después fue recubierta con el
adobe
a ese lugar los llamé la chabola como
llamaba mi abuelo a el cuartito que
tenía en el fondo del terreno donde él
se metía los domingos y jugaba a ser
albañil
las construcciones de adobe tienen que
estar en las zonas altas del terreno en
el caso de mi terreno era listo entonces
había que rellenar una parte porque si
corre agua que corra por otro lado
además de mantener un buen alero
hablé con un amigo que trabaja con
camiones y suele a veces tener este
tierra para ir a tirar al basural
le dije cuando sea apta para relleno
dejarla en mi terreno así que empezaron
a aparecer camionadas de relleno en la
zona del terreno donde yo le pedí pero
además venían con regalos una escalera
rota por ejemplo una maravilla había que
arreglarla y ya se podía usar hierros de
construcción retorcidas sólo había que
enderezar las en fin empezaron a
aparecer otros elementos que además iban
cobrando otro sentido
para construir la chabola calculamos que
había que les íbamos a necesitar más o
menos una camionada de arcilla y 3
camionadas de arena
porque el material está relativamente
cerca está ahí en la base del cerro que
está a 500 metros pero hay que traerlos
a la obra así que compré una camionada
de arcilla dije bueno ahora tengo que
comprar 3 camionadas de arena y estaba
ahí en el terreno
pasa un hombre con un camión y me dice
necesitas tierra para el relleno me
gritas de su camión digo no se retiene
maestro pero a ver me acerque qué tipo
de tierra tenés no estamos sacando y
cerca de la playa y hay que llevarlo a
tirar entonces agarré el relleno
supuesto que decía y no servía porque
era muy arenoso y tenía conchillas
y genial llegó la arena que tanto
necesita cuanto me puedo extraer de
estos 34 cambia nada justo lo que
necesita así que sólo hubo que zarandear
y ya tenía la arcilla y la arena a eso
se le agrega el fardo que les llamamos
que es la alfalfa cortada y con esos
tres elementos básicos se hace el adobe
bueno fuimos construyendo la chabola con
cosas que iban apareciendo regalos una
abertura una puerta por ahí un día salí
de la verdulería con mi bolsa de
verduras y mira había una batea me asomo
había una hoja de una ventana de
algarrobo con los vidrios así que me fui
a mi casa con la bolsa y en la ventana
otro día pasé tres banderolas que hacen
juego de tres tamaños distintos bueno
así parecía como que algo me ayudaba
como un viento a favor que me decía
seguir que vas bien
con mi compañera mariela en el mes de
septiembre decidimos meternos a vivir en
la chabola porque teníamos que dejar de
alquilar y esto apremiaba
le hicimos una terminación este por
dentro para adaptarlo digamos a que sea
una casita la chabola creció para arriba
creció para el costado pudimos hacer un
entrepiso y en septiembre como les decía
nos metimos a vivir con nuestros dos
hijos cuadrúpedos y peludos charo y
romeo que son labradores
poco espacio para cuatro personas sabía
y
así que dijimos septiembre ya está va a
venir el buen clima
entonces nos cagamos de la risa el baño
había quedado afuera a 6 metros
el buen clima no vino en septiembre
tampoco en octubre tampoco en noviembre
en el centro de la patagonia del calor
muchas veces llega recién en diciembre
en fin fueron tiempos duros nos dimos
cuenta que hay el mismo viento que hace
30 años les decimos que nada no los
vientos son los de antes no cuando sos
el primero que recibe el viento te das
cuenta que son los mismos así que
paralelamente a esto habíamos podido
hacer los cimientos del proyecto de la
casa de gabi y quedó ahí parado en el
tiempo la la platea con 16 columnas que
son postes de madera había que meterse a
vivir en un lugar y nos metimos en las
chabolas pero bueno era muy chico pasó
todo ese verano en el adobe se trabaja
en los tiempos de mejor temperatura pues
se trabaja mucho con las manos y en el
invierno se proyecta o se hace
estructura o se acopia material cuando
llega más o menos esta época es el
momento de ir afuera y trabajar
planeábamos en el invierno que hacemos
empezamos con la casa o unimos la
chabola con el baño porque con mariela
nos mirábamos y decíamos esto lo
tendríamos que haber hecho a los 25 ya
estábamos cerca de los 50 que va a ser
así que él fue que decidimos que la casa
espere es un año más y hacer la
comunicación la unión otro ambiente
entre la chabola y el baño y pasar a
tener el baño adentro de la casa que
siempre hayamos tenido desde que nacimos
pero esta situación nos ayudó a valorar
lo que es una ducha caliente adentro de
la casa una maravilla
bueno en esta segunda etapa también
probamos otros tipos de pared la técnica
como por ejemplo se llama se ve como es
como el hornero pero a lo bestia digamos
ya mucha más cantidad de el barro pero
es el barro arriba del barro moldeando
con las manos paredes más anchas y
macizas
la mejor pared que yo vi
ahora que está construida y que vivo
dentro de ese lugar
no conozco nada más térmico ni más
acústico que esa pared maciza de barro
y además volvieron a aparecer los
regalos aberturas un amigo dijo tengo
una puerta vieja y que la iba a usar la
tengo guardada hace 20 años no la querés
y la que él
mis viejos cambiaron una ventana a la
que la quiero y así las aberturas del
espacio donde estamos son todas
distintas en una ventana moderna con una
antigua con esa puerta que vino de bahía
blanca de un remate
y cuando uno recicla
muchas veces hay que tener en cuenta al
pensar en reciclar que ese objeto tiene
una vida previa tiene una memoria que no
la va a perder va a reencarnar en una
nueva vida
y además va a estar el trabajo que
nosotros le pongamos yo me imagino que
la puerta de madera charla con la
ventana sobre sus vidas anteriores y
sobre ésta
eso le dan toques mágicos a estos
espacios
así que ahora
ya sé cómo quiero que sean las paredes
de mi futura casa
ya sé qué va
que va a estar construida con las manos
con la cintura con los tendones con el
corazón de todo lo que trabajen ahí
me acuerdo de diego y otro vídeo
constructor
que me dijo esto es un viaje de vida
cuando empecé yo no entendí bien
y también recuerdo un pintor que había
alguna vez una entrevista que él pintaba
sus cuadros manchas de colores
pinceladas de colores sin que hubiese
una forma y arriba de eso pintaban más
colores al otro día y capas y capas y
capas de distintos colores hasta que un
día decía basta el cuadro está terminado
porque él se daba cuenta que el cuadro
lo había pintado a él
a mí me pasa lo mismo
es como decía diego esto es un viaje de
ida ya no hay camino de regreso porque
la bioconstrucción me termino
construyendo a mí yo ya no siento miedo
de lo que es hacer una casa porque ya no
me acuerdo cómo era
acaba de estar va a haber esfuerzo de no
sólo mío de mi familia de la gente más
cercana que me ayuda muchísimo
y nunca voy a olvidar que todo empezó
con el primer metro cuadrado muchas
gracias
[Música]